now getting into probability theory so
during your school times or college time
you would have learned about probability
theory what is probability theory yes as
we shall said it is actually chance the
chance of getting for example if I'd
toss of coin okay I am tossing a coin
and what is the probability of getting
my head it is actually 1 by 2 only one
time my head can occur that is as I am
initially it is 0.5 so that's what it is
represent here the number of favorable
occurrence to the number of possible
occurrence so the number of possible
occurrences if it also kind either I can
get a head or a tail so there are two
possible occurrence but when it turns a
coin only one can be the result so
either I will get a head or else a tail
so it has divided B 1 by 2 if I am
talking about probability of getting a
coin which is head then I can tell it is
1 B 2 which has equal probability in
terms of coins but an example if I am
rolling a dice what is the probability
that I get a number called two dice
generally has 6 face yes as I mean you
said it is 1 by 6 so only one option can
occur either 2 3 4 or PI or 6 any one of
these numbers can occur but there are
actually six faces so the probability is
1 by 6 that is what we are going to look
here and in another way so for an
example let us look at a case study okay
so in this particular case study I have
hundred points okay I am going to toss
hundred coin sorry I am going to toss
ten coins so I have ten points and I am
going to toss 10 coins simultaneously
okay this is the process and how many
times it is possible to get ahead so if
I am tossing n coins what is the
probability of getting no heads what is
the probability of getting 1 head what
is the probability of getting two head
and this is actually the thing that I am
going to choose yeah as I'm going to
said it is 0.5 into 10 but I am going to
repeat the process for 100 times so
first time I am going to toss 10
parallely okay and I'm going to record
how many times head head occurred and
the second time also I am going to talk
hundred and the second demo so I am
going to toss ten coin simultaneously
and I'm going to record how many times
head had occurred okay I am repeating
this process 100 times if we are looking
at this frequency see so what being at
bed actually made a survey so they had
tossed ten coins and they had repeated
this experiment 100 times so don't get
confused so I'll just tell okay I am
storing 10 coins simultaneously and I am
going to do this operation hundred times
okay hundred times I am going to repeat
the same process so first time I will I
will toss 10 coins second time also I
toss ten coins the same I am tossing the
ten coins 100 times okay and I had
recorded the frequency so I I just see
that only in this hundred times only one
time I found that no heads turned up
okay all the ten coins were showing me
tail that frequency is only one and two
times
it showed only one head and nine days
and three times it showed two hits and
eight days okay this is actually the
number of heads which I have it so here
just tell me which is the maximum
frequency which is the number which had
maximum times you said occurred on
looking at this frequency this is
actually if you are adding all these
things it comes to 100 100 times to
experiment is done in only one
experiment I found that all may 10
concert a
and in only two experiments I find that
only one head turned up and the rest
nine conjugate
okay as Matthew said five hit 30 times
so in 30 experiments I find that pi
times I get hit and ply tails I sign so
this is having maximum frequency so
according to us if I if I toss a coin if
I if I it tossed 10 coins simultaneously
the optimum probably the maximum
property that I get is five five times
hit five heads will occur and pi tails
would occur
that's that is the maximum occurrence
that is here so that's what we're going
to see here and this would give you the
relative frequency for every flips but
an example if I ask you a question what
is the probability of getting zero head
when I am tossing 10 points what would
be your answer
if it has ten coins all the ten coins at
a I am NOT getting not even a single
head what is the probability it is zero
0.001 this relative frequency would tell
you what is the probability this is
nothing but 1 divided by 100 because in
100 experiments only one time this
scenario had occurred so one divided
high by 100 is 0.01 2 divided by 100 is
0.02 because if you are adding up all
this frequency it comes 200 so
individual value divided by hundred and
30 divided by 100 would be zero point
three here
if I am asking question what is the
probability of getting 5 heads when I am
flipping
10 points what is the probability
what is the probability that I get five
heads in this particular scenario this
actually 0.3 0.3 would be the
probability so 4 5 times head 0.3 is the
probability and what is your expected
value so before I toss a coin okay we
are not talking about this experiment in
a general way I am asking a question
okay
I am tossing 10 coins simultaneously
what is the probability for me to get
head what would be your answer how many
said pipe on what basis you said 5 this
is actually your expected value right
you didn't do any experiment but you are
arriving at a particular value you guess
that okay whenever I toss 10 coins
simultaneously at least 5 times I can
get head at least 5 coins will turn up
head that's your expected value that's
that that's where this expected value is
calculated so the method to calculate
expected value is nothing but 0 into
your frequency so into your relative
frequency so if it if you are
multiplying 0.01 into 0 it becomes 0
your relative frequency into the number
of heads so this is 0.02 into 1 it
becomes 0.02 0.03 into 2 it becomes 0.06
and if you are adding up all this values
together 5.14 yeah so 5.14 is the
expected value so according to our
analysis initially before doing this
experiment what was our expected value
if I toss 10 coins 5 is the thing that I
am going to get pi times I assume that
at least 5 heads would turn up even
after looking at the expected value now
we are guessing that it is PI 4 and 1/4
so it is closely near to fight so fight
em it can turn up that's how the
probability works ok and if I am asking
the probability of individual things
doctor for an example if I ask you a
question what is the probability of
seven times head occurring when I clip
10 coins what would be an answer your
answer would be 0.12 right this is the
probability here about the probabilities
and expected values expected as nothing
but your assumption so initially you
would have some assumption what is it
overall assumption that it gives and
the maximum maximum number which is
occurring this is all about probability
distribution so generally if you know
the probability it's sometimes help you
in knowing some business process for an
example in the same in the same cases
just connected with customer getting
into your company and getting a
particular product okay
so initially on a particular day 10
customers are getting into your shop and
they're getting chocolate coffee and
then they say in the same way what is
the probability that tomorrow if there
are 10 customers how many customers
would if you want to take the
probability that 5 customers are getting
odd copy I can derive from this
probability values that's what we also
relate the same example with some of the
business cases and you can do it ok this
is about probability distribution and if
you're looking at in our slide
interstate also this will be represented
so this is the same way like they took
another example how many units sold on
the first day like here at different
days for 10 days zero units sold for 55
days only one unit actual for 150 days
two units [ __ ]
the same example they had given for
another business case so sales data for
AC sold in last 300 is in last 300 is
how my AG is getting sold so in lastly
in three days only 10 days I found the
10 days there is no same in 55 days I
found only one unit sold in 150 days I
found two units sold so this is actually
the frequency we just mentioned and here
the probabilities are calculated
correspondingly and which is being
plotted here you can see at an average
level how many units are sold at an
average level three units are sold this
this would be your expected value right
clear agreement the same thing in terms
of business example they had given let's
go through this example and it is also
the same process next coming to binomial
distribution so because we will not much
get into the statistical part or a
mathematical part so what we'll is
because some people are from business
background and some people are from max
background so what I will do is I will
try to put all these things in a
employee so that that's why that's the
reason I had created another slide but
they generally on looking at at a
complete slide it is difficult for you
to understand the statue on Sep so
that's why I had also created some
additional slides to represent all these
examples okay so for an example what is
binomial distribution okay as I can
shall say it is two values so whenever
you have two situations like probability
of success or failure or the event
happening or not happening in those sort
of situations only if we have if your
values are like if you have a fixed
number of trial and if we have the
trials of independent of each other then
you can go for a binomial distribution
and it has only two options say that a
success or else a failure
so in those sort of situations you can
go for a binomial distribution
so only one probability of success and
the other things would be a failure so
what L does I will also show the slide
that I had created for an example
binomial system distribution let's not
get much into a technical part okay
suppose a Dyess task fight ends so how
many sides a die has it has six sides
and what is the probability of success
this what is the probability of success
in a dice it is 1 by 6 and what is the
probability of failure it is actually 5
by 6 yeah so in this case what I am
going to do is what is the probability
of getting exactly two folds so if I if
I if I roll a dice and and if I am doing
the same process five times what is the
probability of getting exactly two fours
in this case it becomes easier so one
thing is you can do okay as I'm gonna
said one byte that is I am just yes one
way that is it when you are accounting
spy times for a single die it would be 1
by 6 right yeah yeah that is option
Incendia you are telling 2 by 5 out over
does 2 by 5 what is 2 by 5 because of
two fours yeah
it cannot be related in that way so I
will just tell you how to do this
process this is the process you are
clear about one die faces rate what is
the probability it is 1 by 6 and just
make sure that this I will be taking in
terms of
formulas and I also tell you how to do
this in Excel in a easier way
first I'll tell you the formula how to
do this process okay
the formula to do this is binomial
distribution errs the formula is NCR NCR
n would be capital n see our
p ^ R into Q to the power of n minus R
this is the formula this probably you
would have learnt in your colleges or
school so here let me explain let me
once I put it in in a formula basis and
I will do this process and again I will
explain you how this is happening in
terms of tool very easy so what is
exactly n here how many times we had
repeated this process what is n this is
the formula to calculate binomial
distribution so it is pi pi times I
repeated the process so Phi the
combination of what is R here how many
times four should occur it is 2 so it is
2 and what is P is nothing but the
probability of success what is the
probability of success when you are
rolling a dice
it is one by six yeah so if you are
dividing one by six in calculator what
is the value
1 by 6 ^ what is our here it is 2 and in
the same way what is the probability of
failure
q is nothing but your probability of
failure it is PI by 6 if their success
is 1 by 6 it is minus of your success
rate it is 5 by 6 ^ what is n what is n
here Phi Phi minus 2 so can someone tell
me what is Phi C ^ PI combination of 2
what is pi combination of two
what is the value of someone said it is
free but basically we will also do PI C
pi C ^ - what you will do this I will
also tell you what is the formula for
this this is nothing but n factorial
divided by R factorial into n minus R
factorial I'll just put this formula
just for your understanding this is
nothing but n factorial if you want to
calculate mannerly by hands also you can
do it n factorial divided by R factorial
our cultural into n minus R the whole
factorial okay and if you are
substituting in this formula what is the
answer that you get five c2
what is n factorial here 5 factorial is
nothing word PI into 4 into 3 into 1
yeah
5 & 2 4 & 2
one / so when it was this I'm just
giving a detailed explanation and what
is our factorial
what is our control here okay I think
everyone had did this process everyone
had given the uncertain but just for the
first process I will do this this is
actually two factorial
to factor into n minus 2 is nothing but
5 minus 2 is 3 3 factorial so 3
factorial would be 3 into 2 right so
this is actually 3 into 2 it gets
canceled then 2 will cancel by 2 so this
is actually 10 so 10 would be the result
of pi C 2 instead of 5 c 2 now we can
substitute 10 okay 10 into what is the
result
1 point 6 1 by 6 into 1 by 6 the power
up to what is it what is the result you
have point here one way 6 would be 0.167
0.167 to the power of 2 into the failure
would be 0.833
^ 5 minus 2 is actually 3 and if you are
solving this you would get a result of
0.16 bind right
this is the probability that you would
get this is the result that you would
get using formula in the same way if I
am doing the same process in Excel let
me see how how how much time it is and
now it is the probability so if I ask
you a question what is the probability
what is the probability for me to get
exactly two folds when I toss fighting
the dice what is the probability it is
0.16 with 1/6 when the same thing you
can do very easily in terms of Excel so
just open your Excel here this type what
is the operation that we are going to do
what is the distribution that we are
going to do now we are going to do
binomial distribution so this types
binomial you will get binomial
distribution option
so in this binomial distribution you can
see the number to specify here what is
the number that we are going to take
here how many times four should occur so
the number of time exactly four should
occur is two times and what is the
number of trial it is five and what is
the probability of success
what is a probability of success it is
one basics okay
inputting 1 by 6 and the cumulative
cumulative something very important to
understand so now we are going to do a
point probability so in terms of point
probability you have to select false as
your option I will tell you what this
what is the cumulative probability and
what is point probability so now we are
able to see the result right what is the
result
even when manually calculating 0.16 one
it is 0.16 0 7 5 8 can be accounted as
0.16 one it is equal to rated it becomes
very simple in terms of Excel now in the
same way if I am asking you okay send
get repeat again so what I will do is I
will do the same process again binomial
distribution okay what is this number of
s number of s represents that how many
times that your number should occurred
so in our case exactly four times the
number should occur it I will show you
the question once more suppose a die is
tossed pi times what is the probability
of getting exactly two fours so what is
the number that are expecting exactly
two fours that's what I had mentioned
here as to first number is actually I'm
mentioning I want to exact force and how
many trials I had made
how many times I handmade Israel pi
times I had made a grade and what is the
probability of getting a success in a
dice
one basics so I am giving one by six
year and it is very easy in Excel
because it throws you what are all the
parameters to pass and cumulative here I
will talk about point probabilities then
I will talk about cumulative property as
well so first I will talk about point
probability which is exactly four okay
so here I want only on this particular
point what is the probability so I will
select my operation as false okay
clicking it and closing a time clicking
enter I get the probability value yes
males and they are clear about this
process okay now what the question that
I had framed is exactly two numbers what
the exactly two fours so what I did
and also so the first question what I
did us exactly two times the number four
should occur this is what I did so here
what I can do is the probability of X is
equal to four
this is the X is equal to two x it
should occur the same way if I want to
find less than or equal to two P of X
less than or equal to two in this case
what would be my value what should be my
value so I should calculate the
probability of zero because if it is
less than or equal to two
I should calculate the probability of 0
I should calculate the probability of
one probability of two right in the
situation
in this case if I take only one
probability that is sufficient this is
called point probability because I am
doing this operation for only one
particular value which is a pointed
value I want to know exactly to push to
occur but what if this may have a
question okay at least two times it
occurred so in that case what you'll do
is P of X less than or equal to two here
what you want to know is you want to
know the probability of 0 x occurring
and you want to know the probability of
one time the value getting occurred
and you want to know the probability of
two times the value Gator Creek
here this is what you have to be so
first what I will do is I will take a
now instead of false instead of this
particular false if I give true the
cumulative actually happens if I give
true here this is actually cumulative
distribution so this is actually the
probability of 0 1 & 2 gets added so
what is the probability of 0 1 & 2 all
together for less than or equal to 2
what is the probability in another way
what I'll do is
let's copy this
so first time zero times it is occurring
okay
what is the value 0.40
and now I will just put the value here
as one only one time the value is
occurring okay
you
and now I will put the probability of
two times the value get occurred okay
now if I add all the strings this is for
what the probability of X is equal to
zero
zero this is actually the probability of
X equal to one
and this is actually the probability of
X is equal to 2
this is all this points are in digital
probability rate this is point
probability what are the chance of zero
time occurring what is the probability
of one time occurring what is the
property of two time occurring this is
exactly zero this is the value exactly
one this would be the probability
exactly two this is the probability so
whatever if we want X less than or equal
to two what I should do
these are all like point probabilities
I'd phone now we want to calculate the
total I have the summit of yes if I sum
all these three values
what is the value that I get 0.96 for
5:06 which is nothing but if you are
mentioning as true the cumulation
happened if you are mentioning as false
the point probability happened now is it
clear for everyone
one thing is you can take point
probability of all the points and you
can add or us directly with the last
value you can divide you can mention
your cumulative as proof then all are
automatically the accumulation happens
is it clear everyone now is it clear for
everyone with this example
this is how the binomial distribution
works either you can calculate point
probability and you can add or as you
can mention your accumulation is true if
you're mentioning accumulation as false
it is point probability if it is true
then it is a cumulative probability okay
next I will get into the other
distribution so in the same way that's
what as I gave you an example here they
had given so now can someone tell me
with this particular problem don't stir
CD and say okay just tell me what is the
probability of updating first tell me
what is the probability of obtaining
exactly 40 way heads in hundred
thousands of coins can someone tell me
for exactly 45 first tell me exactly 45
then tell me the cumulative probability
score during this process what are all
the factors that I should consider
exactly 45 times I want to know exactly
what if a times how it is occurring and
also copy this question
in this question what is the formula
that I should put here
what is the instead of obtaining fewer
hits first consider exactly 40 wait once
the question is just tell me the point
probability of exactly for deeper heads
okay 0.048 so I'll also check it once
okay so equal to binomial distribution
what is the number of parameters that we
are fixing exactly 45 right
and number of trails we had made 100
trails and what is the probability of
success here
tossing a coin it is 0.5 yeah one by two
0.5 anything is okay and what is a
parameter that I should mention for a
point probability Falls a true
I should mention false yeah the mention
falls
this is 0.048
and in the same way if they want to find
what is the probability of less than or
equal to fortified or fewer heads of
fortified then what I will do is I can
make it true here I will get a
cumulative option
okay fine so this has a probability of
heads occurring less than or equal to 45
here everyone 18% chance
you